Desiree starts off this hour in Wichita
Falls Texas hi Desiree how are you
stressing this how are you I am better
than I deserve how can I help
I'm just looking for some advice to get
through my panic mode right now we just
found out this week that we knew we were
having another baby we didn't know we
were having - yay so you're having twins
yes we are also except for I'm two
months away from being debt-free for
$145,000 so we were so excited thinking
we were going to you know do everything
the right way this time and have no debt
and just take things as they come paying
cash but now it seems like we have to
buy everything out there really I mean
these kids I feel like they're not even
going to three car seats aren't
connected in my vehicle and the thought
of spending four thousand forty thousand
dollars on a new car is just totally
making me panic and I was just accepted
into graduate school that we're planning
on cash flowing that starts two months
before the baby's ours do so I'm just
trying to decide I mean I don't want to
take the lesser of the evil in the debt
world you know what I mean or don't but
part of me is thinking it wasn't here
here's the thing that's happening okay
you've decided that with this news
there's all these mandatory things that
have to occur and the great news is is
you're in control of your life so just
step back and erase the whiteboard and
let's start fresh okay number one all of
us listening heard you say and we all
laughed when you said it that the only
cars that I hold three car seats are
$40,000 and we all want it yeah you are
stressed because your brain quit working
obviously that's not true okay lots of
cars all three cars leads that aren't
$40,000 and they're perfectly safe to
put little pay
and so you'll be fine so what kind of a
car have you got now I have a small Jeep
crossover okay
and what's it worth honestly probably
maybe ten thousand dollars perfect and
what is your husband make a year I'm not
sure I know what we make together okay
what do you make together we make about
130 so what do you make I think we're
even he's probably let's just say he
makes 70 I make 60 and so a $10,000 car
sold and buying another $10,000 car that
holds three car seats is an extremely
logical idea completely works and now we
have the car seat thing solved without
any stress now if you got a little money
I didn't even ask about that yet you can
move up a little if you want we want to
freak out now you set a hundred and
forty five thousand and student loans or
something it's a gone away you paid off
that much in two months that will be
will be finished that in that'll be
cancer how much is left now nothing how
much is left man let me see right now is
eleven thousand oh great really okay and
the babies are do win in September
awesomeness so that you'll be debt-free
when they get here right yes and do you
have any money saved at all just my
thousand dollars our thousand dollar
emergency fund okay perfect perfect and
what does your husband drive he drives a
Ford f-150 okay
not a three car seat car either yeah so
sometime between now and September we're
going to make a car move and we're going
to be debt-free I'm feeling better
already
so the only question I've got and you
know you're gonna have to have another
baby bed but I think you can afford that
you make one hundred and thirty thousand
dollars a year you're going to be
debt-free okay but I'm also training for
a graduate school
oh maybe maybe no I just got accepted
well nobody said it's not federal law
let you go just because you're accepted
I know but I've been trying for
so long to go and then I said okay I can
do this with a newborn and a toddler and
we could cashflow school will be fine
and now the school starts in July and
then the babies are due in September and
we're moving in June moving where we
have no idea yet one because he's in the
army oh so you know we have no control
you're 128 years old you're 28 years old
um no I'm 26 26 pretty good guess okay
all right my daughter's 26 so I'm gonna
play Papa Dave here okay okay
delay grad school and here's why I said
that
okay you got too much on you you're
moving your husband's in the military
you got an extra baby you're trying to
finish up getting out of debt and you
got to trade cars delay grad school your
life is not going to come to an end
those babies are there and grad school
will be there another year and by the
way when you move you don't know where
you're moving but you've already been
approved for grad school you're doing it
online no so it's for I'm a nurse so the
first year portion is online okay and
then like a year and a half after that
is all clinical rotations yeah I mean it
I would just take breathe little you
don't have to you can put your Superman
cape back in the back in the drawer
there kiddo okay let's just be a mom and
being a nurse and be a wife and get your
car and it's okay and then you know next
year you can decide if you want to
pursue this graduate work and buy the
kid and the kids are up running around a
little bit and you know they're starting
to go the bathroom by themselves and all
that stuff right it's helpful because
some of the stress level goes down but
you're getting ready to have double
trouble for a while now we've got we got
two grand kids running around and not
running around but they're under one
year old and when they're both in the
house it's it it's all hands on deck to
manage two of them and an avid
two-year-old yeah yeah we got one of
those runners who we Sharon and I had
all three of them the other night and so
we had your mix but they were grandkids
and when we sent them home we were glad
we loved them but we love them but my
god we were like the young people need
to do this stuff and so you know later
and I just don't want you to get you
know the if you all of these demands you
put on yourself are not their demands
you put on yourself and you get to
choose other stuff you can do whatever
you want to do you're obviously a very
bright young lady and thank you to your
husband for serving this country you
guys are a neat couple I can tell by
talking to you but I just say you know
you can put your Supergirl cape back in
the drawer for a little while and just
enjoy the ride a little bit and grad
school look good school always be there
I'm not saying don't do it but maybe
don't do it this year because it's just
stacked up and I'm with you you doubled
up you doubled up your stress level with
this blessing of news but it's going to
be double the fun and double the trouble
and you're going to have to buy a few
little things here or there but you guys
are going to be just fine I think you
just try and do three things or 63
things at once and I take a couple of
them off my plate that way I'm not
dropping food in the floor you know kind
of way it feels you do what you want but
that's me looking in from the outside
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you